-Republicans are already rushing
to fill the Supreme Court seat
left by Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and forced through a
conservative super majority
that will help them cement
minority rule for a generation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look.".
♪♪
So yesterday, a friend of mine
gave my youngest son an apple,
and he showed him
how you could shine it
by rubbing it on your shirt
like this.
And then my son
started doing it,
but he did it after each bite
he took,
thus covering himself
in apple juice.
Each time,
we tried to explain to him,
"That's not how you're
supposed to do it,"
he just laughed harder
and harder.
My point is I'm glad that
also happened this weekend,
because otherwise,
this weekend was the worst.
There are few words left to say
about Ruth Bader Ginsburg's
legacy that haven't already been
said.
She's a feminist icon
who was already
the leading litigator
for women's rights
in the country before
she joined the high court
and became one of its most
iconic and influential justices,
and in addition to everything
else she accomplished,
she was also a fierce defender
of democracy.
For example, she delighted
audiences by brandishing
the pocket Constitution
she carried with her
wherever she went.
-So, if I take out my pocket
Constitution,
which it carry with me wherever
I go in the world...
[ Laughter ]
So here it is.
-Amazing. She was
as knowledgeable
about the Constitution
as anyone in history,
and yet out of reverence
for the document,
she still carried it around
with her.
Watching RBG reach into her tote
bag for her pocket Constitution
is like watching Batman
reach into his utility belt
for his grappling hook.
And of course,
you'd never see the latter,
because no matter
where you stand on Batman,
he clearly lacks
the crowd-pleasing
show-and-tell warmth of RBG.
And she was Brooklyn,
so something tells me
she busted that thing out a lot.
"'Scuse me, lady.
You can't park here!"
"Let me just take out
my pocket Constitution."
"Oh [bleep] It's RBG!
Run, boys!"
Ginsburg was an incisive jurist
and legal pioneer
as recently as May.
She called into the
Supreme Courts oral arguments
from her hospital bed
to advocate
for Obamacare's protections
for access to contraception.
-She kept attending
oral arguments.
When the arguments
went by telephone
after the COVID pandemic,
really shut down this court
in March,
Justice Ginsburg
continued to participate.
In fact, it was in May when she
had the gallbladder condition
where she went to the hospital.
She actually participated
in the oral arguments
from her hospital bed
at that point.
Incredible. Not only would I not
participate in a conference call
if I were in the hospital,
I know multiple people
who have pretended
they were in the hospital
to get out of conference calls,
unless that is one of my writers
actually has something called
Blort's disease.
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
was an intellectual titan,
a tireless advocate of equality,
a relentless guardian
of democracy,
and a towering figure
in the history
of American jurisprudence
and civil rights.
And if Republicans
get their way,
her successor on the court
will be chosen by this guy.
-Okay, that was
the first little time.
Then he went, "Donald Prump.
Yeah, Donald Trump.
I love Donald Trump."
I got the Nobel Preace Prize
nomination,
a peace prize, Nobel,
nomination.
We will defend
the dignity of work,
and we will defend
the sanc--
the sanctity of life.
America will land the first
woman on the moon,
and the United States
will be the first nation
to land an astronaut on Nars.
-Oh, man, dude.
I don't think you are gonna win
the Nobel Preace Prize.
Seriously, what's going on here?
Just because your presidency
feels like a root canal
to the rest of us doesn't mean
you have to take the novocaine.
I mean, did he just have
dental surgery?
Did they take out
all of his teeth?
And did they replace them
with gummy bears?
He sounds like Siri after you
drop your phone in the toilet.
Siri? Can you name the planets
in the solar system?
-Nercury, Benus, Glearth,
Nars...
-Okay, okay. You know what?
But that's right. Donald Prump
won the Nobel Preace Prize
because he defends
the sank of life
and will put an astronaut
on Nars.
Whenever he talks like that,
I expect him to turn around
and reveal that he has leaves
in his hair.
Remember a few weeks ago
when Trump insisted
he didn't have a series
of mini strokes,
despite the fact that no one
claimed that he did?
Is that because they were
maxi strokes?
I'm not saying he was lying,
but watching that,
even I smelled burnt toast.
I mean, he can't even
say his own name.
He called himself Donald Prump.
That sounds like
an off-brand Disney character
you'd find at a toy store
in Russia.
[ Russian accent ] Donald Prump.
Is fun. Is fun.
Come for two-for-one.
You get Jared Pushner.
Jared Pushner, tiny,
skinny little doll.
He can talk, too.
[ High-pitched ] I am under
qualified for my job.
[ Lower pitched ]
Is two-for-one.
[ Normal voice ] Although I have
to say Donald Prump
is a much more accurate name
for him.
You know, like a character from
one of those old
claymation Christmas specials.
[ Old man voice ] Hey, look.
It's ole Donald Prump.
Santa says
he's on the naughty list
'cause he hangs out
by the liquor store
and buys beers
for underage kids.
[ Normal voice ] And this
isn't even the first time
Trump has gotten his own name
wrong.
I mean, once,
he called himself Ttump.
I guess those cognitive tests
come with your name
pre-filled in.
You know you get 200 points
on the SATs
just for writing down
your own name?
Trump might be
the first student in history
who got a negative score.
But this is how [bleep]
everything is --
the president
of the United States
can't even say his own name,
and we can't, as a nation,
take a few minutes to enjoy that
because of, you know,
the death of democracy
and stuff like that.
In fact, this weekend,
Trump went full fascist
by celebrating the supposed
good genes of his supporters
and celebrating police violence
against a journalist
who was covering protests,
MSNBC's Ali Velshi.
-You have good genes.
A lot of it's about the genes,
isn't it? Don't you believe?
The racehorse theory.
You think we're so different?
You have good genes
in Minnesota.
I remember this guy, Welchi,
he got hit on the knee with
a canister of tear gas.
And he went down. He was down.
"My knee. My knee."
[ Scattered laughter ]
Nobody cared.
These guys didn't care.
They moved him aside.
And they just walk
right through.
It was the most beautiful thing.
No, because after we take all
that crap for weeks and weeks,
they would take this crap,
and then you finally see men
get up there
and go right through --
Wasn't it really
a beautiful sight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, first of all, Prump,
his name is Velshi, not Welchi.
Second, in addition
to being explicitly
and unapologetically fascist
to call for state violence
against journalists,
it's also absurd
to listen to this celebration
of physical violence
from one of the biggest
physical cowards in the world.
I mean, you hid in a bunker
because there were protesters
outside the White House,
and you nearly wet yourself
because of a bird.
♪♪
Right after that clip, the eagle
gave him two for flinching.
The closest you've ever come
to a fist fight
is sounding like
you're answering
the referee's questions
after taking a foot in the head
from Ronda Rousey.
What year is it?
[ As Trump ] 1985.
[ Normal voice ]
What planet are we on?
[ As Trump ] Nars.
[ Normal voice ]
What's your name?
[ As Trump ] Donald Prump.
[ Normal voice ] Okay.
Okay. He's done.
Or, you know, if it's
a Republicans ref...
He's good to go!
Four more years, champ!
Also, you really want to
talk about good genes?
Your brain is ricotta cheese,
and you look like
a Halloween decoration
that's been out on the lawn
since last year.
You should be on the stoop with
an orange bucket in your lap
and a sign that says
"one piece per child."
So, Senate Republicans
who represent 15 million fewer
Americans than Senate Democrats
are pulling out all the stops to
help a sundowning fascist
who lost the popular vote
by 3 million
to fill a Supreme Court seat
vacated by a feminist icon
six weeks before an election.
And, Trump, of course,
has signaled
that he's fully on board.
-The president tweeted this out.
-I have begun work to fulfill
my constitutional duty
to nominate a justice, another
justice of the Supreme Court.
We have an obligation.
We won, and we have an
obligation as the winners
to pick who we want.
That's not the next president.
Hopefully,
I'll be the next president.
-Even if you win,
you're not really going to be
the next president. You're
barely the current president.
We're at 200,000 deaths and
almost 7 million COVID cases,
And you spent the weekend
golfing at your private club
and slurring your way through
another rally
like a drunk guy at karaoke.
[ As Trump ] I'm gonna do Bowie.
♪ Is there life on Nars? ♪
[ Normal voice ]
But you heard the president.
Republicans should move
without delay.
[ Sarcastically ] To be fair,
at least it's consistent
with his position from 2016,
when Merrick Garland --
Look. I don't need to do this
whole fake, sarcastic setup,
right?
You guys just roll the clip,
and I'll think about my son
and his apple again.
-I hope that our Senate
is going to be able,
Mitch and the entire group,
is going to be able to do
something about it
in terms of delay.
I think it's up to
Mitch McConnell
and everybody else to stop it.
It's called delay, delay, delay.
-Now, look. I get that
highlighting their hypocrisy
is mostly pointless.
Hypocrisy only matters
if you have shame.
They don't.
Mitch McConnell certainly
isn't capable of feeling shame.
He looks like a haunted wooden
doll you'd find
in an estate sale
and has the same level
of emotional complexity.
Their bad-faith justifications
were obvious [bleep] back then,
and their bad faith reversals
are obvious [bleep] now.
But it's still worth taking
stock of just how insulting
and transparent their lies were,
and remembering that
for the future
because it's not just hypocrisy.
It's nihilism.
They're moral black holes
who only care about
the raw exercise of political
power.
And plus, we went
through all the trouble
of gathering the tape,
so we're going to play it.
And while I do it, I'm going to
pass the time
by getting started on a project
I have been meaning
to get around to.
I am going to crochet a blanket.
And I will try to get at least
a corner done.
I mean, how long could this clip
package take?
-Senator Chuck Grassley,
the Chair of the Judiciary
Committee himself,
said it only makes sense that
we defer to the American people
who will elect a new president
to select the next
Supreme Court justice.
-The American people should
be afforded the opportunity
to weigh in.
You can't have one rule
for Democrat presidents
and another rule
for Republican presidents.
-I believe the next Supreme
Court justice ought to be
chosen by the American people,
through the election of the next
president.
I think this -- that we're
too close to the election.
The president, who is elected
in November,
should be the one who
makes this decision.
-The Senate will approx--
appropriately revisit the matter
after the American people finish
making in November the decision
they've already started
making today.
The American people are
perfectly capable
of having their say,
their say, on this issue.
So let's give them a voice.
Let's let the American people
decide.
-It has been 80 years since
a Supreme Court vacancy
was nominated and confirmed
in an election year.
There is a long tradition
that you don't do this
in an election year.
This should be a decision
for the people, George.
Let the election decide.
-I don't think we should be
moving forward on a nominee
in the last year of this
president's term.
I would say that if it was
a Republican president.
-The American people
need a chance
to weigh in on this issue
on who will fill that seat.
They will have that chance
this November,
and they ought to have
that chance.
-This is about principle.
Not the person the president
has nominated.
And it's why the majority
of the Senate has chosen to use
this unique situation
as an opportunity
to let the American people
have a voice.
-I want you to use my words
against me
if there's a Republican
President in 2016
and a vacancy occurs in the last
year of the first term.
You can say Lindsey Graham said,
"Let's let the next President.
whoever it might be,
make that nomination."
If an opening comes
in the last year
of President Trump's term,
And the primary process
is started,
We'll wait to the next election.
And I've got a pretty good
chance of being the judic--
-You're on the record.
-Yeah.
-All right.
-Hold the tape.
-Holy [bleep]
[ Chuckles ]
Just in time for fall.
Jesus!
That montage was so long,
my hair grew out again
and again.
I get that the hypocrisy
is baked in.
Pointing it out won't change
their minds.
It's like telling
a middle school bully,
"Giving me a wedgie
won't make your parents
get back together."
He knows that.
He just wants to give you
that wedgie.
Still, it's worth documenting
just how obvious
and degrading the lies were.
And remembering this the next
time they pretend to care
about some obvious [bleep] like
cutting the deficit
or respecting the courts.
Also, it's striking just how
specific their promises were.
"This is about principle.
I'd say that if a Republican was
president.
Use my words against me."
I'm shocked Lindsey Graham
doesn't get up there
and say [As Graham]
Mark my words.
If 45 days before the 2020
presidential election,
An iconic liberal justice
passes away and requests
as her dying wish that she not
be replaced
until after the election,
which is taking place during
a once-in-a-century pandemic
Just two weeks after it's
announced that
"Keeping Up With
the Kardashians" is ending,
then you could use my words
against me.
I promise I will not vote
on a justice nominated
by president --
-Donald Prump.
-Seriously, though, when you
watch a montage like that
and then see all the same people
scurrying
as quickly as possible
to reverse themselves
four years later, it's almost
like the lying and the hypocrisy
are the point.
Like, they are trying to rub our
noses in just how shameless
and unaccountable they are that
they don't care about democracy,
that they can do whatever
they want.
For example, when Ted Cruz was
asked about comments from 2016,
he dismissed them as
meaningless.
-Look. We had this fight at the
end of the Barack Obama term.
And at the time, all the
Democrats were saying
"Confirm the nominee.
Confirm the nominee."
And all the Republicans were
saying,
"We're not going to confirm
the nominee."
And so, we've got a situation.
You just played a quote from me
in 2016.
We can play that game
all day long.
-[ As Cruz ] If you want to play
clips of me lying through
my weird, little teeth,
while condescending
like a French waiter
at Disney Land,
we can play that game
all day long.
[ Normal voice ] Democrats
have to internalize the fact
that this is not about
principle.
This is about raw,
political power.
And they need to use every tool
at their disposal to stop it.
The Senate majority
that won fewer votes
than the Senate minority
wants to help a corrupt autocrat
install an unprecedented
conservative super majority
on the Supreme Court, appointed
largely by presidents
who lost the popular vote,
including, of course,
the current president...
-Donald Prump.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men, women, and
children living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other serious
illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.